the best TV shows and movies are the
ones where characters are faced with
moral quandaries that explore the gray
area between good and evil people like
to imagine what they would do in those
situations and can easily see themselves
on either side in real life though we
fit people into black and white
categories a decision is either right or
wrong and someone is either good or evil
we often want to categorize people so
much that will create a fictionalized
version of that person in order to shove
them into one of those two boxes
Christopher Columbus is one of those
people you probably have one of two
views of Columbus you might think that
he was a brave Explorer who proved the
world was round and by doing so
discovered the United States and if
that's the case congratulations on
graduating from elementary school now I
know every grown-up says this but a lot
of things are gonna change for you not
just for you personally but for all the
things that you think you know so enjoy
it while it lasts but odds are you
probably think Columbus was an
incompetent buffoon who never even set
foot in America Christopher Columbus was
actually an idiot and dumb dumb he got
lost coming here and he's the one that
named us Indians cuz he thought he was
in India he was a doofus who was
terrible at math well that's quite the
contrast well let's take a look at the
facts and see if we can't figure out
which ones have been misunderstood miss
attributed exaggerated and sometimes
straight-up fabricated wow that was a
lot of big words I kind of feel like
Johnnie Cochran only way underpaid might
as well start at the beginning right
Columbus couldn't have discovered that
the earth was round because in his time
it was already common knowledge
perfectly ordinary the way Adam phrases
this makes it seem like Columbus thought
he was the first person to conclude that
the world is round
he didn't nor did he ever claim to
people since ancient times knew that the
world was round nobody thought that the
world was flat some people probably
thought the world was flat some people
today think that the world is flat
some people are idiots but I also want
to bring attention to those perfectly
ordinary Globes globes weren't exactly
common back then in fact this is the
oldest surviving globe in
world made in 1493 completely separate
from Columbus here's a question for you
what continent are we looking at you
don't have to answer right now but just
tuck that away in the back your mind for
now this projection of people saying
what they think Columbus thought doesn't
end
especially when it's ridiculous my map
says the earth is teeny-tiny and shaped
like a pear and at the top it has a
succulent nipple he actually believed
that yes I actually believe this do I
actually have to talk about this no he
didn't think that the world was shaped
like a pear with a nipple on top in fact
I had never even heard this claim before
but luckily Adam gives us his source who
actually never says that Columbus
thought that the world was shaped like a
pear in fact she says putting all of
this together
Columbus reason that the world was
shaped like a ball with a breast like
protuberance breasts like protuberance
on his third voyage he wrote a rather
poetic letter describing how he felt
himself not just crossing the ocean but
going up it had he reached the very tip
of the protuberance he would have sailed
straight into the terrestrial paradise
so what does he mean by that
well back in the day maps were often
oriented with east on top not north and
at the very far end of the East or on
top of the map you would find the
earthly paradise also known as the
Garden of Eden this paradise was often
depicted as sitting on top of a
protuberance in one letter in 1498
Columbus Ponder's if this depiction of
the earth might be accurate and then
never mentions it again and also a pen
give me money please
this man is an idiot see what he did
there he took something that Columbus
poetically pondered once during his
third voyage and made it look like he
presented this idea to the king and
queen of Spain they didn't fund his
expedition just to make him go away the
Ottomans had just defeated the
Byzantines and froze Europe out of the
spice trade and since Portugal was going
all-in on conquering Africa and Spain
had just kicked the Moors off of their
Peninsula they were ready to get in on
that whole exploration and colonization
game so what about this whole thinking
that the world was tiny thing that
people keep repeating yeah that's not
true either people knew the
circumference of the earth
more or less turns out Columbus went
with less but still what they didn't
know is how big the ocean was or
how big agent remember when I asked what
continent we were looking at on that
globe its Asia
here's his globe projected onto a piece
of paper and here's a slightly less
confusing version of that same
projection they thought Asia was much
larger but this isn't the guy I want to
talk about because he's not really
connected to Columbus
this is the map Columbus was going by
made by Tuscan le in 1474 this is China
on the globe we saw earlier and this is
China on Tosca Nellie's map it was
Tuscan le who told Columbus the voyage
is not only possible but it is true and
certain to be honorable and yielding
calculable profit miss calculate the
distance to what you wrongly think is
Japan even though people have been
calculating the circumference of the
earth pretty well for centuries using
sticks in the ground and shadows and
math he calculates the journey from
Spain will take him just 21 days he
underestimates the distance by 7,000
miles what's striking about this is that
any educated person at the time would
know that Columbus was wrong
I guess by any educated person they mean
not tuscan le who was widely viewed as
one of the great cartographers of his
time which is why Adam throws this in
the background to make it look like
Columbus wasn't listening to Tuscan le
when he clearly was it's actually pretty
good attention to detail that the map
Columbus was pointing to in that mankind
scene is Tuscan Elly's map so where did
they get that whole 7,000 miles off
thing this is what Columbus was aiming
for sipping goo which is supposed to be
Japan obviously this isn't where Japan
really is but that is where everyone
thought it was it wasn't Columbus's
calculation of the distance that was off
it was any educated persons positioning
of Japan Columbus was also hoping that
there were the uncharted islands off of
the east coast of Japan so when he
landed here that's when he thought he
found it died thinking he had made it to
India people saying that you're not in
Asia insist that you are he didn't think
he was in China he didn't think he was
in India he thought he was somewhere new
off the coast of Japan but still
somewhere new
remember he landed here which there is
no land on the map right year so what
was he supposed to think and here are
the actual land masses
Columbus landed on the island of
Hispaniola which is 7,000 miles away
from Japan that's where they got that
number so I suppose he got kind of lucky
that he accidentally discovered some new
land he didn't discover America and he
didn't prove the earth was round
Columbus was a savage man who didn't
discover North America didn't prove the
earth is round this is something that
you've heard everywhere and it's
probably already down in the comments
whenever Adam says America he's
specifically referring to the United
States which is weird the some news
segment is a little more honest by
saying North America which is true he
didn't land in North America so let's
talk about the guy who did Leif Erikson
in 1985 the Vikings set up two
settlements in Greenland if he didn't
already know this the name was just a
sales technique to get more settlers
Greenland is very much not green which
meant that the settlers had to travel
further west in order to find timber
Erickson's winter camp at Lonzo Meadows
Newfoundland lasted one year before
being abandoned the Greenland
settlements were mostly forgotten by the
rest of Europe during the Black Plague
and they were finally abandoned in 1408
I personally have a problem with people
who say that the Vikings discovered
America first imagine it's 2010 and
someone offers to sell you Bitcoin at 10
cents apiece you decline it because it's
stupid and worthless
now it's 2017 and bitcoin is worth
$10,000 apiece so you go around telling
everyone how you could have been rich
because you knew about Bitcoin back in
the day but you never did anything with
it
okay now swap out Bitcoin for America
and extend the time line out to 500
years the Vikings didn't discover
America first they stumbled on it
looking for timber stayed for a year and
then left and not only did they never
come back but they just plain forgot
about it their find amounted to nothing
Columbus's discovery on the other hand
opened up both halves of the world to
each other and changed world history
forever on his third voyage in 1498 he
landed here which he named the gulf of
pariah and then he named all of this
pariah this is the terrestrial paradise
that he was talking about in that
previous letter he describes that the
land of pariah is a mighty continent
that was hitherto unknown so not only
did he know he found something new but
he was describing the South American
continent he thought that the Caribbean
as well as this new continent lied to
the southeast of Asia which is also what
people like Amerigo
smoochie believed Amerigo Vespucci is an
interesting character in our story
because he was foolish he straight-up
made up two voyages so historians take
what he has to say with a grain of salt
but while he was in the service of
Portugal in 1502 he was mapping the
South American coast and soon realized
that he was further south than anything
previously mapped in Asia so he - we
thought that this must be a previously
unknown fourth continent but his letters
don't describe huge river deltas that
would have been impossible to miss if he
was actually there so this was four
years after Columbus described pariah as
a hitherto unknown continent and just
like Columbus Amerigo thought that this
new continent lied to the South of Asia
so why is it called America the usual
story goes at Amerigo beat Columbus to
the punch when it came to publishing his
findings and the name was eventually
settled on in 1507 by the Waltzing
Mueller Rapp unfortunately it's just not
that cut and dry this is the map the
Universalist Kozma graffia and here's
the new fourth continent named America
the female latinized version of
America's name but appear to the north
we see a smaller fifth continent named
pariahs the latinized you get it
walled see Mueller didn't settle the
dispute or settle on a name he credits
both Columbus and Amerigo in the top
left corner of the map there are still a
few interesting things to note on this
map though like this this is still
sipping goo which is supposed to be
Japan and there are a number of places
on the east coast of America which are
also on the east coast of India which
shows that educated people still weren't
sure if America and Asia were connected
or not anyway the name Piraeus
eventually falls out of favor when they
realized that North and South America
are actually connected though even in
1587 Mercator named the northern half
America or New India so you know it took
people a while to settle on a name so
now that we've cleared all that up kind
of and we're in America we need to
discuss how primitive or not primitive
the Native Americans were people on both
sides tend to lump all Native Americans
in together there are two huge
continents spanning thousands of miles
what's true for one tribe isn't
necessarily true for another if one
tribe mapped all the stars and created
in an almanac that doesn't mean they all
did
if one tribe didn't use the wheel that
doesn't mean they all didn't some of
them did invent a wheel they just didn't
use them for hauling because they hadn't
domesticated draught animals yet I would
have been fine with that statement until
he said the word yet this implies that
given enough time they would have
eventually when no they wouldn't have
ever not because they're intellectually
inferior or anything like that but
because they had a really difficult
spawn point there are no draught animals
or work or pack animals in the Americas
there are no horses donkeys or camels
and because of that they hit somewhat of
a cap on their civilization tech tree
you can't really have large cities
without animals in fact with the
exception of llamas and guinea pigs in
Peru they didn't have any domesticated
animals there were no cows pigs or
chickens to share diseases with so
Native Americans were incredibly
vulnerable and susceptible to disease
again not because of any genetic
inferiority but because of their
difficult starting location since
Europeans and Asian's had been living in
close proximity with animals for
centuries they had built up somewhat of
an immunity to animal diseases like cow
pox chicken pox and the various swine
and avian flu so on Columbus's second
voyage when smallpox was introduced to
the new world it burned through the
entire continent killing 90% of the
Native American population before they
had even heard of a European this was
inevitable and unavoidable
whether it was Columbus any of the
people who followed him or even a
Chinese explorer coming the other way
it was also unintentional at this point
the whole smallpox blankets thing
doesn't happen until way later in the
1700s the point is that by 1690 percent
of the native population had died so
when the first North American colonists
showed up in 1607 and 1620 they found
most of the land to be pretty much
uninhabited pre-columbian population
numbers for North America vary widely
from 50 to a hundred million but
everyone pretty much agrees on that 90%
disease mortality numbers so we're
talking about 5 to 10 million people in
1600s spread across the entire continent
before you go thinking that that's
exceptionally bad remember that a
hundred and fifty years before Columbus
Europe lost 50 to 60% of its population
to the Black Plague these epidemics just
kind of happened
you don't count the quarter-million tyno
people that lived there already occupied
someone lives here
I know this part he thought he made it
to India we've covered this already what
a silly mistake yes if by silly
you mean brutal brutal is not a synonym
for silly the Thai no treated Columbus
and his crew with the utmost hospitality
hug that's not how it happened Columbus
didn't freak out and go get
reinforcements on his first trip he
bounced around a few islands left 40
people to set up a fort and returned
home to report his findings the king and
queen sent him back after only six
months with the expressed purpose of
establishing more permanent settlements
so what did Columbus think when he first
saw the natives did enslave and
brutalize the nice people he found there
our journal entries literally from him
describing the natives being kind and
bringing him things having no knowledge
of guns so they'd be easy to enslave
okay that is a lot to unpack but this is
something that people bring up all the
time that in his own words and in his
own journals he says this or that the
most common quotes are the ones he shows
so let's start with this one about them
making good servants what do you notice
about this quote how about the fact that
it's neither the beginning nor the end
of the sentence there's clearly more to
it so we're gonna have to look it up and
here it is it appears to me that the
people are ingenious and would be good
servants and I am of the opinion that
they would very readily become
Christians as they appear to have no
religion they very quickly learned such
words as are spoken to them in full
context the word servant could mean
slave or servant of God or subject of
the crown when they just cut out the
ingenious good servant part it only
means slave they remove any context and
any doubt but these are Columbus's own
words we have to take them at face value
since we can't figure out what he really
meant right do you see where I'm going
with this yet these aren't his own words
because his real name wasn't Christopher
Columbus it was Christopher Oh Columbo
oh look what do we have here yes I
really do have that kind of time on my
hands here's what we're looking for from
October 11 1492 now we have to translate
it let's just shove it into Google
Translate and see what we get they must
be good servants and I'm good with that
I see that very quickly he says
everything he taught
them blahblah obviously Google isn't the
best translator since it doesn't carry
meaning very well but it takes some
linguistic gymnastics to get from they
must be good servants and of good wit to
the people are ingenious and would be
good servants they picked the absolute
worst most biased translation to quote
as journal entries literally from him
fun fact the Italian translation of his
journals don't have the word servant at
all instead they translate it as servant
of God or for more on how bias can
influence how the same words can be
translated to mean wildly different
things might I suggest watching the
movie arrival I'm not gonna walk you
through the process for every single
quote but there is another one people
like to refer to I could conquer the
whole of them with 50 men and govern
them as I please
here's the Spanish and here's what
Google Translate says because with 50
men they are all subjugated and it will
make them do everything they want ok
that ending doesn't really make all that
much sense but I can tell you what it
doesn't say conquer them and govern them
as I please but just to be sure let's
look at a different translation of the
same quote for with 50 men they can all
be subjugated and made to do what is
required of them the words conquer or
govern don't appear here either
again they picked the worst possible
translation to highlight again in full
context in this section Columbus is
asking the king and queen what they want
done with the natives suggesting that 50
men would be all that's required to hold
the island there is nothing about
governing them as he pleases
and while we have Columbus's journals
open there's one more thing I'd like to
point out let's say I brought a bunch of
Indians back to Europe to show off and
most of them died on the boat ride over
because that's true I did that that
happened just say that you only meant to
bring six in the first place ok well
let's see what he has to say in his own
words conveniently the sentence in
question is right after the first quote
we looked at if it please our Lord I
intend at my return to carry home six of
them to your Highnesses that they may
learn our language this was written two
months before his journey home so unless
they're implying that Columbus had a
time machine and was able to change what
he said from the start and there's yet
another aspect to this that I want to
bring up none of Columbus's original
journals survived all we have are
transcriptions of his journal written by
someone who's probably already been
mentioned
comments below Bartolome de las casas
people often incorrectly say that las
casas traveled with columbus nope he
arrives in April 1502 with Nicolas de
ovando three months before Columbus his
fourth voyage arrived in the new world
as far as we can tell they never cross
paths Bartolome de las casas was a noble
who was given in encomienda in the new
world encomienda was the spanish feudal
system of lords and peasants and that's
what the natives were peasants not
slaves Columbus wanted to subjugate them
which means turn them into subjects of
the crown not enslave them they were
forced to work against their will but
nobody owned them
nobody could buy or sell them in 1515
las Casas gave up his encomienda and
advocated instead for the use of african
slaves that's right the protector of the
natives as he would later be called
advocated for the transatlantic slave
trade which then started under Nicolas
de ovando not Columbus he slaughtered
the opposition and became the progenitor
of the transatlantic slave trade and not
his son either but Diego has built on my
work with the Indians helping to found a
triangular trade route that represents
the world's first multinational process
streamlining the transatlantic free
labor market in sourcing African workers
in 1530 he transcribed a Columbus's
journals and then in 1542 he wrote a
short account of the destruction of the
Indies which is the thing that a lot of
people point to as las Casas saying
Columbus was evil he only mentions
Columbus once and it's rather neutral
really the account is about the people
who followed Columbus most notably de
ovando who is best known for his brutal
treatment of the native tyno people of
Hispaniola keep that in mind it becomes
important later
Columbus was removed as governor of
Hispaniola in 1500 and put in jail not
because of his brutal treatment of the
natives but because of his mismanagement
of the colony which meant that he wasn't
extracting enough gold and because of
complaints from the Spanish colonists
chop off people's hands cut off people's
noses and hands unless they give you
silver right he was doing that to the
Spanish I'm sure he also did that to the
natives but the king and queen didn't
really care about the natives at this
point
but his punishment was that he was
removed as governor and put in jail for
a total of six weeks after which he was
given everything back and sent out on
his fourth voyage so you can see how
much they really cared about punishing
him but it was while he was arrested
that he wrote an important letter girls
as young as nine years old was sold into
sexual slavery my customers wanted new
world sex slaves and I heard them
actually what Christopher Columbus quote
that actual Christopher Columbus quote
comes from that important letter I just
mentioned where he complains about the
robbing and sexual slavery of natives
which is why he cut off colonists hands
and noses and that the violence of the
calumny of turbulent persons has injured
me more than my services have profited
me which is a bad example for the
present and the future am I saying that
Columbus was a good person no but am I
saying that he was against the very
thing that people say he was for yes
that's exactly what I'm saying
yes they're quoting his complaint about
something happening and saying he was
doing it that's talk about taking
something out of context so Columbus was
not governor when las casas arrived las
casas had already given up his
encomienda and started the slave trade
by the time he transcribed Columbus as
journals so at this point he has every
incentive to make Columbus look as bad
as possible in fact it's common
knowledge that he paraphrased and
exaggerated this is made even worse by
black legend which is a propaganda
campaign by English historians to make
the Spanish look much worse than they
really were so when people say from
Columbus his own journals what they
really mean is from one specific 1892
English translation of the 1530
transcripts of Columbus's journals
originally written 40 years earlier I
hate to draw this comparison but it's
kind of like directly quoting Jesus he
didn't speak English what you're
actually reading is a centuries-old
translation of a third-person account of
what he said written hundreds of years
afterwards oh yeah that's another thing
those original transcripts and even the
translations of Columbus's journals are
written in third person to Columbus's
regime was so senselessly brutal that by
1542 the tyno population on the island
gone to 200
as we've already established Columbus's
regime only lasted until 1500 Adam is
attributing an entire 50-year span to
one person 42 of which weren't even
under Columbus do you even remember who
the president was 42 years ago de ovando
who was the most brutal if you remember
was in charge for longer than Columbus
50 years is a long time that's two or
three generations not only was Columbus
dead but his kids were dead I mentioned
this in my organ trail video but this is
another example of someone taking
something that occurred over decades and
compressing it down to blame it all on
one guy 50 years is twice as long as the
Oregon Trail was in use so okay
something else that really stuck out to
me is that 200 number no matter what
source you look up you'll see the 1542
population numbers around 2,000 to 5,000
which is still small don't get me wrong
but it's 10 to 25 times larger than what
Adam says so where did he get this here
by 1542 there were fewer than 200 but
wait a second did you notice something
here Adam says that the tyno population
in 1492 was 250,000 which is pretty
accurate to what most everyone else says
but in Adam source it says the
population was 1.1 million which is
ridiculous so don't use the source when
the numbers are wildly unbelievable but
go ahead and use it when it fits your
narrative I guess so how many people did
Columbus and his men kill and does that
count as genocide if we take that
250,000 number and subtract the 90%
mortality rate from disease the answer
is that it doesn't matter that's not
what genocide means in 2012 George
Zimmerman shot and killed Trayvon Martin
that fact is beyond dispute but he was
found innocent
how is that possible because he was
tried for murder not manslaughter murder
requires an intent to kill Zimmerman
didn't leave his house that morning
saying I'm gonna kill the black kid
today proving intent when the only
witness is the perpetrator is nearly
impossible and intent matters when we're
trying to define a crime after the Vegas
shooting a few months ago many people
wanted the crime labeled as an act of
terrorism terrorism is the use of
violence or the fear of violence to
further a political agenda there was no
stated political purpose or message be
the shooting it was just a senseless
mass murder the intent is what matters
so when we look at what happened with
Columbus and his men there's no denying
that mass killings took place I am NOT
trying to deny excuse or minimize what
happened but when trying to label the
crime as genocide we have to look at the
intent genocide as defined by the UN is
an act committed with intent to destroy
in whole or in part a national ethnical
racial or religious group Columbus is
intent was not to like in his own words
he wanted to subjugate them
it wasn't racially or ethnically
motivated it was conquest motivated and
those who resisted were killed when
Napoleon was trying to take over Europe
he killed hundreds of thousands and we
don't call that genocide the end result
is the same whether we're talking about
Trayvon Martin the Vegas shooting or
Columbus people were killed and that's
awful but when trying to label a crime
as manslaughter murder terrorism or
genocide it's the intent that matters
for centuries Columbus was a historical
footnote but that changed in 1828 when
Washington Irving the author of The
Legend of Sleepy Hollow and other tall
tales
wrote the first english-language
biography of Columbus historical
footnote right that's why this state
capital the district of the nation's
capital this state capital and this
territory were all named after him not
to mention all of the other cities and
counties in the US and an entire country
in South America all before 1828 truth
is that Columbus and his imagined female
goddess form Columbia have been part of
the American story since the beginning
here she is telling you to ration food
during World War one and here she is in
the painting that you all know even if
you're not American as the depiction of
manifest destiny admittedly American
folklore has probably turned him into a
bigger deal than he should be given his
rather minimal involvement in US history
which is why I personally don't think
that we should have a day to celebrate
him but conversely I also disagree with
just renaming it indigenous peoples day
because what is it really
Columbus Christopher Columbus that's a
big it's just anti Columbus Day think
about it what do people do on indigenous
peoples day they hate Columbus burn him
in effigy and hold mock trials of him if
you want to have a day where we
celebrate native history and native
cultures then let's do that
don't just name swap it and make it hate
on Columbus Day we don't have a day
where we hate on objectively more evil
people like Hitler or Stalin it's weird
was Columbus a good guy no was he a bad
guy if we look at him through the
historical lens not really he wasn't any
worse than anyone else but if we hold
him up to modern standards yeah he was a
pretty bad guy Columbus is just one part
the first part but a relatively small
part in what happened to the Native
Americans so why do people hate Columbus
or rather why do people want to hate
Columbus why do some people seem to
exaggerate and in some cases fabricate
evidence in order to discredit downplay
and demonize him
well Wonderwoman got it right maybe
people aren't always good you don't
think I wish I could tell you that it
was one bad guy to blame it's not day
ovando was objectively worse Cortes and
the other conquistadors were objectively
worse and the US government most of the
time anyway was objectively worse but
even more than that all of the unnamed
soldiers under these people were the
absolute worst but despite all of that
Columbus is the one that everyone can
name too many people Columbus deserves
none of the credit for discovering
America but all of the blame for what
happened to it if we can pin 400 years
of awful history onto one guy it shifts
all of the guilt for what happened to
the Native Americans away from the rest
of us well the rest of you because my
relatives didn't come over until after
the close of the Indian Wars so not me
putting people into nice neat little
boxes of good and evil just isn't that
simple people are more complicated than
that and deep down we all know it we
just don't want it to be true we want a
villain to blame and the next time
someone tells you that Columbus was
responsible for the genocide of millions
or they tell you that he thought that
the world was shaped like a pear
hopefully now you know better so what do
you think was Columbus the most evil
evil who ever evil or just a man of his
time whose story should I deconstruct
next let me know down in the comment
and don't forget to discover that
subscribe button yes this is chocolate
and I can't wait for all of you to tell
me how dangerous this is in the comments
below at least it'll be a nice change
from everyone calling me a racist when
you're done with that follow me on
Facebook and Twitter and join the
conversation on the subreddit
[Music]